so I've recently taken on an opportunity
which I wanted to share with you guys
because it's I'm really really excited
about it and also it's a slight slight
shift in terms of what I have been doing
and what I've been learning and what
I've been talking about so for those
that have sort of been engaging with me
over the last sort of 12 months or
however however long thank you so much
I'm excited about sort of engaging you
with you now and also in the future
about the new things that I'm gonna be
doing and yeah I just wanted to make
this short video to sort of explain my
fault process and what I've been talking
about and learning all that sort of
stuff so for just over two years now
I've been in recruitment absolutely
loved it I've learnt so so much from the
guys where I work and also just from the
daily challenges as you know of being a
recruiter so no no way at all do I think
that I know everything about it I don't
feel like that no way there's still so
much so much to learn but what I have
learned over the last sort of six months
or so which I've been really really
fascinated about is using today's tools
to make my life easier as a recruiter in
terms of leveraging social LinkedIn all
the good stuff to build candidates
relationships get my message out there
build a personal brand and yeah I've
absolutely loved all that which is why I
do all this sort of stuff on the weekend
don't see it as work all that sort of
stuff so what's happened is basically
there's a business called hook so media
which I'm gonna be joining now what
these guys do and what they are they are
a specialist marketing agency for the
recruitment industry which I found
absolutely fascinating I've been
following their journey since they've
started and that's the business and
they're the guys that I'm going to be
joining so I'm now going to be in a
position where I'm gonna be learning
full-time how recruitment businesses and
recruiters can leverage today's tools to
make their life easier in terms of the
leads that they get generating more
leads and also helping recruitment
nurses grow their businesses by creating
an employer brand and all that good
stuff so firstly I'm really excited
about learning about all that sort of
stuff because I've just been learning as
I go really
and doing it in my current day job as I
have been and secondly I'm going to be
speaking to recruiters and recruitment
business owners on their daily basis
talking about this stuff which I'm
really passionate about which hopefully
you guys have recognized I'm passionate
about the industry I absolutely love the
industry and what was given to me so I'm
hoping that people will see see that and
see the sort of correlation in what I've
been doing but I just wanted to be open
and honest with you guys that only
slightly change I'm still talking about
recruitment because I'm learning from
you guys because you're now essentially
my clients or the people that only
didn't move on a daily basis which is
quite cool and yeah I'm really excited
to see how it unravels I'm gonna be
continuing on here but I'd love to sort
of hear your thoughts on what you think
that and all that sort of stuff there
will be people think you're making a
mistake or whatever how long is it going
to last
which I get it is a risk but I'm excited
about it it could not pay off but that's
how it is it I've really following my
intuition on this because I really feel
like in the next five years the social
element of recruitment is just gonna get
more and more emphasized and gonna be
more and more important so I'm really
excited which I'm hoping you guys could
tell and yeah looking forward to engage
and build new relationships now and also
in the future